Bhupati patel is an old hand at this
he's been farming since he was a
teenager here in Eastern Mudder Pradesh
growing pulses and cereal crops but
these aren't Patel's fields today his
other friends are in the midst of the
wheat harvest and he's struggling with
painful memories in mid-march unseasonal
he'll hit the neighboring district with
Patel's own four acre farms located the
storm battered his crops and pushed him
to a mental breakdown the hailstorm
completely destroyed my chickpeas I had
borrowed money too so the crops my first
thought was how will I repay the loan I
was shocked I couldn't think straight I
swallowed some pesticide too in my life
Patel was rushed to hospital where he
spent days recovery he's still weak and
suffers from frequent dizziness and
nausea he's not sure when he can work
again at the beginning of the year Patel
took a bank loan of over 2,500 euros to
buy seeds and fertilizers rent a tractor
and hire a farmhand he also borrowed
from moneylenders to cover his family's
expenses the debt burden kept growing
our crops are a lifeline if they fail
where do we get money from I now have no
source of income for the rest of the
year I felt there was just no way out
for me I wanted to die lupard Patel is
not an isolated case and it's not
confined to states like multiple dish
across India hundreds of debt relief
farmers have committed suicide over the
years the agrarian crisis is a major
issue in the ongoing Indian election
with all political parties trying to woo
farmers
on the outskirts of Jabalpur the
opposition Congress party is holding a
campaign rally its leader Rahul Gandhi
is promising a separate budget for
farmers a complete loan waiver and his
bowing the criminal proceedings will not
be allowed against farmers who default
on their loans nearly 70% of India still
relies on agriculture for a living
experts say there's a lot of political
rhetoric around this huge voting bloc
but little will to tackle the underlying
crisis what India needs to do what
political parties need to do is to go
into the root of the agrarian crisis on
how farmers and farming can become the
crucial engine of economic growth in
India that's where the solution is for
now there's no sign of that at the local
wholesale market farmers have come in
from surrounding areas to sell the grain
and vegetables the government sets fixed
prices for certain commodities to
incentivize production but farmers here
say they're not getting those prices the
overriding view here is that farming
simply isn't viable for Bupa Patel -
there's little hope left that things
will change he sees no future in farming
all he wants is for a son to find a job
far removed from the precarious world of
Agriculture joining us for more
professor Himanshu he teaches economics
at Delhi's Jawaharlal Nehru University
professor good to see you now india's
farming crisis has been going on for
quite some time now why has it not yet
been addressed well there are a number
of reasons for this but let me just say
that agriculture is shed in the GDP is
now the lowest less and less less than
15 percent now it's not in the priority
list of the government's who are trying
to drive growths further up compared to
other countries but also because the
nature of agriculture has changed
agriculture has become much more
vulnerable because of the globalization
of the economy the nature of production
in the agricultural sector has change it
has become much
cash-based also governments over the
years have had been not investing as
much amount of money as is required for
an agriculture which has changed
dramatically in the last twenty to
thirty years so I think a combination of
all these factors and led to a situation
where agriculture continues to remain
vulnerable to external shocks weather
shocks as well as domestic internally
internal economy shocks you spoke of
money there now in terms of money both
the ruling BJP and the opposition
Congress have offered a financial
support for farmers in their manifestos
in this election season is that the
right approach you think I mean
obviously they're all both of them in
fact all political parties whether it be
the state government or the single
government are trying to treat the
symptoms when the crisis is on the
street and farmers are on the street
protesting against low prices or the
crisis in the economy this I think is
the best solution for that the
politicians could think of but remember
this does not address the real reasons
as to why the economy is in crisis and I
think the amount of money which is now
being given as a symptomatic relief of
kind of a thing if it was invested back
in the structural issues foreign issues
which basically lead to a better
productivity and better incomes to
farmers over the long run long period of
time that would have had a much better
result compared to this kind of
situation where every five years or ten
years you keep on pumping money to the
in the aggregate in economy more as a
dole more as some kind of a short-term
solution the other than as a long-term
investment in agricultural economy what
really would you say needs to be done to
tackle this farming crisis a lot of
things need to be done I mean the first
thing I think the first in the foremost
in that sense is to bring agriculture
back on the priority of economic policy
immediately in the sense agriculture may
not be contributing much to the GDP but
it still is where roughly half of the
entire workforce is and therefore for
livelihood issues agriculture is
something which is very very serious but
the nature of Agriculture has changed
and that needs to be understood it
cannot be the old-style Green Revolution
kind of a method that is what the
comments are still trying to or the
subsidy related mechanisms that the
government is still trying to pursue it
has become much more vulnerable but were
monetized much more cash based and it
has also become much more difficult to
predict what is going to happen in terms
of agricultural prices so I think you
need a kind of
series of policies to bring together all
these issues think of new ways of
dealing with the agriculture bring new
understanding of what the change is
challenges to agriculture are and then
only you can think about finding
solutions to the problems thank you very
much for explaining that to us professor
Himanshu from Delhi's Jawaharlal Nehru
University thank you